if you take a look at nasa's budget
breakdown you won't be surprised to find
companies like spacex
lockheed martin and boeing near the top
of the payout list
but surprisingly the number one spot
doesn't go to any of these space
companies
the largest portion of nasa's funding
actually goes to the california
institute of technology in fact in the
fiscal year of 2020
caltech received a total of 2.8 billion
dollars from nasa
which is over twice the amount second
place received this isn't a new
phenomenon either
in 2021 so far they have received 1.3
billion dollars
in 2019 caltech received 3.6 billion
dollars
in 2018 caltech received 2.7 billion
and this same pattern can be traced back
for decades
every single year caltech receives about
10 to 15 percent of nasa's entire budget
so why does nasa pay cal take billions
every year
well the strong link between nasa and
chaotic today
dates all the way back to the 1930s in
the 1930s
caltech was a relatively new university
with only about 40 years of history
but despite the relative youth celtic
was already starting to receive
worldwide recognition for their
brilliant alumni
celtic didn't hand out its first
doctoral degree till 1920
but just three years later in 1923
robert
and millikan would become caltech's
first nobel laureate winner
such impressive feats for such a young
university attracted some of the best
professors
in the world to teach at caltech even
albert einstein would periodically teach
at caltech throughout the early 1930s
considering the intelligence of caltech
students and professors at the time
it's not surprising that in the 1930s
one of their professors
theodore von carmen started to work on
rocket propulsion
professor carmen didn't have the
smoothness of starts though the tests he
conducted initially were not only
inherently dangerous
but would often fail making it even more
dangerous
so in order to avoid endangering
students and the public living near the
college
professor corman and several graduate
students would move their operation to a
dry canyon near pasadena california
the group's first test in the new
location would take place on october
31st
1936 and this date would eventually be
known as a day the jet propulsion
laboratory was founded
the group initially focused on
alcohol-powered rocket motors
and as they started to make progress
with their motors professor carmen would
decide to expand the scope of the
program
around this time world war ii had just
begun and though the us hadn't
officially entered the war
they were quite involved in supplying
allies like great britain
noticing this professor carmen would
talk with the us army air corps
and he would be successful in persuading
the army to fund their little research
team
the army would help the team acquire a
piece of land in the canyon
and they would give them access to a few
air bases for testing purposes
the idea was that the motors the group
was developing could be used in
conjunction with military jets
to allow for takeoffs from super short
runways mass development
and implementation of their motors
continued throughout the early 1940s
the us army would test the team with a
new project that was much more important
in 1943 the army would request that the
team look into the german v2 rocket
program
as a result the team would put together
a detail to plan a slash funding request
and they would submit it to the us army
this proposal would be the first time
that the team referred to themselves as
the jet propulsion laboratory
the request would be approved and jpl
would develop and launch various
missiles throughout the rest of the
1940s
and early 1950s the main result of their
work throughout these years was
autonomous missile technology
anyways as world war ii came to a close
and tension simmered down
a new war would start up which was of
course the cold war
in 1954 jpl would approach the us army
requesting permission to team up with
them
on an upcoming satellite launch
unfortunately
this request would be denied however jpl
would be allowed to work on a classified
project relating to nuclear warhead
reentry
jpl would end up flying three suborbital
missions between 1956
and 1957 which proved that warheads
could be safely recovered from space
meanwhile the navy would attempt to
launch a rocket called vanguard in
december of 1957.
the rocket would barely leave the ground
before it fell back and
exploded considering this tremendous
failure jpl
and the army would be allowed to try the
following month and
on january 31 1958 jpl
and the army would successfully launch
explorer 1 which would become the first
successful satellite launch by the us
given this massive success and
increasing pressure from the soviet
union
the u.s would decide to form a space
agency on october 1
1958 the national aeronautics and space
administration
or nasa would be founded and just two
months later on december 3rd
1958 jpl would be transferred from the
army
to nasa so why does nasa pay caltech
billions every year
well jpl was basically the foundation of
nasa
they give nasa substantial knowledge in
terms of solid and liquid rocket
propulsion systems
guidance systems telecommunication
systems testing facilities
and much much more but all of that was
just the prologue
the partnership between nasa and jpl was
just getting started
throughout the 1960s jbl was shifted
away from developing rockets
and into developing robotic spacecrafts
the first two projects jpl would
accomplish with nasa were the ranger
and surveyor missions both of these
projects were focused on photographing
the lunar
surface rangers 7 8 and 9 were launched
in 1964 and in 1965.
these robots were designed to take
pictures of the moon as they descended
to the lunar surface
and destroyed themselves following these
missions we would see the launch of
surveyor 1
3 5 6 and 7. unlike the ranger missions
these robots could safely land on the
lunar surface and continue to take
pictures
moving on jpl would start to turn their
focus to other planets in the 1970s
they would complete marine emissions to
mercury venus and
mars mariner missions were flyby
missions that took pictures of the
various plants as they passed them
or orbited them after the mariner
missions
jpl would start work on arguably their
most iconic project which was of course
the warrior missions voyager 1 and 2
are a pair of spacecraft that were
launched in 1977 and in 1978.
since then the pair have just continued
to venture deeper and deeper into space
in fact in august of 2012 warzone 1
would become the first spacecraft to
enter interstellar space
voyager 2 would also hit this milestone
in november of 2018.
it's crazy to think that these
spacecrafts were designed and launched
nearly 50 years ago at this point
nasa estimates that we should continue
receiving images and data from the pair
till 2025.
despite their solid progress with these
spacecrafts as we enter the 1980s
public interest in space started to
decline as a result
nasa's budget would start getting cut
which would consequently lead to cuts in
jpl's budget
as well due to the budget cuts jpl would
scale back from its pace missions for a
little bit
and focus on solar and battery
technology however
nothing too significant would come out
of this endeavor and jpl would face a
massive problem at the start of the
1980s
given the stark decline in the interest
for planetary exploration
congress would actually consider
shutting down jpl in september of 1981.
this is actually super ironic one of the
key reasons for nasa's rapid success in
the space industry
is jpl but now that the us had won the
space race
congress wanted to shut down jpl
honestly
that's kind of messed up fortunately
though caltech trustees as well as the
scientific community
would rally behind jpl and protest the
closure and thankfully
congress would not only listen but they
would go ahead and fund new planetary
missions
as well this would allow jpl and nasa to
complete the maglin raider mission to
venus
and the galileo space probe mission by
the end of the 1980s
the next major phase for jpl would be
martian rovers
jpl would work on developing a pair of
martian rovers throughout the 1990s
called the spirit
and the opportunity the spirit rover
would end up being launched in june of
and it would successfully reach mars the
rover collected data
and took pictures till may of 2009 when
a couple of its wheels got stuck in the
martian stand
nasa would attempt to rescue the rover
for two years but with no significant
progress
nasa would end effort in may of 2011.
meanwhile
the opportunity rover was launched just
one month after the spear rover
in july of 2003 opportunity would reach
mars in 2004 and it would communicate
with nasa all the way till june of 2018
at the time a martian dust storm would
cut off communication between the rover
and nasa anyways after opportunity
nasa and jpl would of course launch a
curiosity rover in 2011
which is still operational to this day
and
more recently nasa and jbl just landed
the perseverance rover on mars in
february
looking forward jpl has a handful of
missions that they are working on
right now for instance the mars
helicopter mission took flight just last
month
they've also got the near-earth
asteroids cap mission occurring in
november of 2021
the asteroids mission occurring in 2023
and sphere x occurring in 2024
at the end of the day this was just a
gloss over of the most important
contributions of jpl
to nasa jpl has worked on countless more
missions like the viking
and europa missions but i think the
missions covered in this video provide a
solid view
as to why caltech and jpr have been so
integral to nasa over the past few
decades
and why nasa continues to fork over
billions of dollars to caltech on an
annual basis did you guys realize that
caltech played such a big role in nasa
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys think jpl is underrated and
deserves more credit
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one